last night's mtv vmas had us buzzing
over the fashion just as much as the
performances we're here with our fashion
producer shreya and blogger christian
thompson to chat all about the hits and
you know the misses so who really did it
last night like
what was your favorite look of the
evening
i think the favorite for me was lizzo i
feel like when we think of the rhetoric
around women's fashion it's always to
look smaller to look slimmer to take up
less space like when we think flattering
flattering is oh it makes you look
smaller so i love seeing someone that
is like a role model for body positivity
taking up more space on the red carpet
coming in a look that was so high
fashion
i loved her hair i love the makeup
everything was on point i think my
favorite though was chloe bailey i
thought she looked amazing
like it was giving futuristic it was
giving space it was giving body it was
she looked great she looked like a
sexier moon man trophy yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh my god
i think lil knots x he gives what needs
to be given
and he is just we know him for fashion
we know him for art we know for taking
risks he likes attention and he deserves
it so i was into it
who did we want more from here
my miss
and i i feel bad saying it because i do
love her
taylor swift
i know i know you guys i know i do
usually love oscar de la renta for me
this look it looked tangled it looked
like my headphones in a tote bag like it
just wasn't working for me it was giving
cat's cradle i know she won a big award
but for me the miss was miss taylor
swift
i wanted more from jack harlow i felt
like i've seen that look before and i
just think that the vmas it's the one
time you can have so much fun with your
looks and he didn't give it to me it's
the place to go to like make a statement
and have fun with your love what were
the trends that you noticed across the
board when you dress up like a celebrity
you usually pick their vma look those
are supposed to be the most
memorable iconic pop culture looks
people will do an homage to those old
really iconic vma looks so i think we
saw it with anita we saw it with mona's
skin both paid homage to the lil kim
purple iconic
breasts so i really liked that yeah